hey guys and welcome back to the lay
High open show today Bitcoin is pumping
and we need to find out why it's right
now at 19 200 for the first time in
months we're also going to speak to an
expert to find out whether Bitcoin
really can fight censorship so joining
me today to have this conversation is
Ryan conjant the founder of lumerin
Brian welcome to the show how are you
today
doing good today's a good day yeah it is
a good day Bitcoin is pumping it's the
highest it's been in a very long time so
I'm really excited to have this chat
with you so before we get into all of
this um let's just get a little bit um
about your background
um and also explain to me what what
lumarin is in its simplest terms
okay
um so I'll try to keep it uh succinct as
possible uh I got into Bitcoin mining in
late 2012. uh my buddy Kyle came to me
and told me about this crazy thing
called Bitcoin
um I was super skeptical at first but
the more more I uh got involved in the
forums the more I read about it the more
I just realized that
um this is really just a revolutionary
technology for Value transfer
um got really heavily into mining
um started writing profitability
calculators and Mining tools and
Hardware Discovery or Hardware
comparison sites and all sorts of fun
tools uh early on
um we launched a company called Titan in
2018 for mining management software and
then we pivoted to uh larger better uh
more optimized Bitcoin mining pools and
we launched the lumren network last year
um so lumerin is a decentralized routing
protocol so this idea that we can create
digital piping underneath all the other
networks for routing information from
socket to socket based on Smart contract
rules that gives us really cool
um a really cool toolbox for creating
things like decentralized digital
Commodities and the first one that we're
starting with is flashpower
so let's get into this and unpack what
all of that means um you know because I
titled this can Bitcoin fight censorship
and from previous conversations that
I've had with you I understand that
lumerin helps decentralize Bitcoin
better
um so in some ways would you say that
mining right now is somewhat centralized
um and if you provide this Marketplace
for the hash power does that make it
more decentralized and would that be a
good thing
yeah so right now um there's a couple
areas of centralization and Mining so
one is you have incredibly large mining
facilities we'll pack
um you know thousands of these little
toasters in you know facilities all
around the world and there's typically
one or two decision makers on where
those toasters are pointed
um you know just to give people a recap
of you know what we're dealing with here
is you have an Asic which is a a
specifically designed machine for one
type of algorithm so in this case it's
Shaw 256 for Bitcoin and if you show
someone this you know little metal box
with you know hundreds of chips in it
with fans on it and you say if you plug
this in it's going to print money for
you well if you show that to a really
wealthy person they're going to be like
okay how many can I have and where can I
put them so you have people that don't
necessarily have a lot of technical
background we'll be pumping you know
tens of millions of dollars into these
machines and they're just putting them
all around the world where they can find
cheap electricity favorable governments
and stable infrastructure
so now you have more centralization
around you know just these use heavily
in um
I I guess uh very large facilities that
have lots of investment money in them so
there's a lot of centralization around
there
um the the next layer of centralization
is around the pools so you know right
now if we really look at the full
ecosystem we really have two pools we
have Foundry and we have amp pool
um you know ample actually is the back
end to a lot of other pools as well
that's kind of the the secret that no
one wants to talk about so ample
actually is the largest pool in the
world you just don't realize it because
there's other pools with their branding
on top of ample so you think it's a
different pool but it's really not so
you know we saw a an article come out
last week saying you know Foundry and
amp will have mined 51 of the blocks
over the last couple months in reality
they've been mining the majority of the
blocks for probably over a year now but
no one's been talking about it so I'd
say those are the two main areas of
centralization where lumer and helps
with this where the the hash power
Marketplace helps with this is it really
brings more decision makers into the
room so if you have a Mining facility
with a hundred thousand of these little
toasters in it rather than one person
deciding where all these toasters are
mining to you can actually put all of
these miners up for sale on a
decentralized Marketplace you know what
we're calling that a hash rate grid if
you will rather than a power grid and
now anywhere in the world someone can
buy this hash rate and they get to
decide what mining pool they send it to
so more decision makers uh more pools
will equal greater decentralization and
future security
so for those for those that don't fully
um understand the difference between
centralization decentralization why is
it important to decentralize the Bitcoin
Network further
um so this is a great uh great question
because a lot of times people get
um confused between uh decentralization
and uh distributed right so what's
decentralized versus distributed
um distributed this is this idea is you
have it all over the place right so you
have a lot of locations it's distributed
decentralized is actually a matter of
control is who has control over the
locations so I could have a say a Mining
facility or compute company and I have
data centers all over the world right
now I'll say like Google Google has data
centers all over the world they're
incredibly distributed but they're all
controlled by Google so it's actually
centralized because it's actually a
matter of control now the kicker with
Bitcoin is we want to spread out the
control because we want it to be
completely censorship resistant when it
comes to governments or any institution
or authority it has to be completely
decentralized so not one entity can
actually control it that's why it's
really really important that it's both
both distributed and decentralized so
distributed Bitcoin nodes all over the
world miners all over the world
decentralized lots of decision makers
all over the world deciding how the
Bitcoin network is actually used and how
the protocol is propagated
and you do this by creating this
marketplace where people can buy and
sell hash power
there we go there we go now we can see
you better
um so you do this by decent by creating
a Marketplace of hash power where people
can buy and sell it so can you explain
what hash power is for those that don't
know and how does that make it more how
does that make the Bitcoin Network more
decentralized
yeah so we we can go uh pretty far down
the rabbit hole here but I'm gonna try
to keep it as simple as possible as
simple as possible
um so when you're solving a Bitcoin
block so a Bitcoin block is actually a
block of transactions
um that is hashed and you have to solve
um what they call a difficulty Target
okay now this can get pretty complicated
pretty fast so essentially what these
miners are doing um these little
toasters if you will they're guessing
numbers really really fast okay
um to the tune of you know the current
Hardware is about 140 terahashes a
second that means Terra hash is uh is
trillion hashes so that means you're
saying 140 trillion guesses a second is
how fast these things are guessing
numbers
um that's a lot now if we were just
guessing lottery numbers we would
probably solve the lottery like that
um but we are guessing in this uh realm
of shot 56 along this elliptical curve
algorithm so the the guesses is so
astronomically large that it takes about
an average of 10 minutes for all of
these miners all over the world guessing
an average of 100 trillion hashes a
second to find the solution to this
puzzle okay so that's what we have is we
have have these these toasters that are
guessing numbers really really fast and
whoever finds that magic number that
unlocks the puzzle is the one that wins
the the prize of solving the Bitcoin
block okay
um so that's that's essentially you know
what what mining is
um so for the hash rate Marketplace
um hash rate is you know how fast it's
guessing numbers and it's it's compute
power it's it's you know these these
machines are burning a lot of
electricity and uh creating a lot of
heat and a lot of noise in order to
guess these numbers
um and this compute power is valuable
because it's um you know over time you
know you will guess the right number and
you will unlock a Bitcoin block and
you'll get a reward uh mining pools will
actually pay you out for the work
incremental work that you do every 24
hours so what individuals will do for
the hash power Marketplace is they can
buy hash rate from anywhere in the world
anonymously so you can be in the middle
of the jungle in Brazil and say I want
to mine Bitcoin and as long as you have
an internet connection or some way to
access the marketplace you can connect
your web free wallet you can purchase
hash power and you can point the hash
power towards a mining pool of your
choosing and it's your account you
actually receive cash power directly and
you forward that hash power onto your
mining pool now no one knows who you are
no one knows where you're boarding the
hash power it is actually your digital
commodity as though you're buying
electricity off the electricity grid
um or I'm sorry off the power grid
um so you know this idea of making a
Bitcoin fully decentralizes this idea of
bringing more decision makers into this
buying process into the decision
decision process of where to send cash
power
um hopefully I answered the question
because that can get a pretty Cumberland
pretty fast yeah it can get very
technical I think the way that I would
say is sort of like the the hash power
is is in simple terms this isn't going
to be completely correct but is the
computational power needed to basically
mine the Bitcoin and create Bitcoin and
it's very hard sometimes to get hold of
that kind of Technology it's very
expensive sometimes you know the whole
infrastructure is a lot so in order to
just but being able to have the ability
to buy the hash power and then go ahead
and mine it yourself
um no I I think it's it's really useful
especially because many countries right
now are obviously cracking down on
bitcoin um especially Bitcoin mining and
more specifically we saw China ban it
and obviously the US are stepping up
their regulations so how does this help
circumvent government regulations and
enable people in all sorts of countries
the opportunity to mine Bitcoin
yeah we touched on us a little bit you
know I I don't want to propagate a
message of circumventing your
governmental laws
um obviously if you are under a
governmental Authority that is saying to
you know not use electricity in a
certain way or you know transact with
cryptocurrencies in a certain way like
I'm not going to contradict that but
um with Bitcoin it is borderless it is
global it is decentralized and somewhat
Anonymous
um so when we have something that
powerful where you can literally move a
billion dollars from one address to
another address uh in a matter of
minutes and no one is going to know who
you are where it came from or where it's
going there's no other Financial rails
on the face of the Earth that can do
that right now
um that's that's Bitcoin That's The
Power of Bitcoin we actually saw that a
couple years ago where uh someone
actually moved a billion dollars between
one address and another address they
paid about seven hundred dollars to do
the transaction and did it settled in
about like 30 or 40 minutes and it was
completely Anonymous
um people just saw the transaction
happen
um and no government was seemingly
involved and no Bank was sittingly
involved so I mean that's true Financial
Freedom and that's that's why we're
doing this is because it allows you to
control your money
um now half power is actually Bitcoin
over time like uh so if you have hash
power over time it equals Bitcoin okay
it's the
um there is a direct ratio there if you
have a certain amount of cash power for
24 hours it will equate to a certain
amount of Bitcoin so if you have a
country that does not allow you to buy
Bitcoin or say they're locking down the
rails for acquiring Bitcoin where you
have to go through some type of kyc AML
process not really naming any countries
here but you know a lot of people know
what those acronyms mean for a reason
uh it does lock down the ability for
people to acquire Bitcoin right and it
is taking this incredibly free uh system
and it's it's trying to put Shackles on
the on-ramp and off-ramp of the system
we already see exchanges if you want to
move from Bitcoin into Fiat uh unless
you actually do it in person in cash
with someone there is going to be
controls in a lot of governments right
now that are trying to keep you from
moving in and out of cryptocurrency
what's amazing with hash power is you
can take any compute power anywhere on
the face of the Earth and you can
convert it into Bitcoin you could mine
Bitcoin on your cell phone you can mine
Bitcoin on your tablet you can find
Bitcoin on your computer really any chip
uh in most of our devices are capable of
doing the shot 356 algorithm now the the
mining Hardware that we see at scale
obviously can guess these numbers a lot
faster than what your cell phone can do
um so the amount of Bitcoin you're going
to earn on your cell phone is is
almost not substantial compared to what
you can get with one of these mining
machines right so what we want to do is
we want to provide Global Anonymous
decentralized access to real hash power
so these these machines that are um in
bulk in these facilities all around the
world that have cheap electricity good
infrastructure and favorable governments
you can now buy that hash power anywhere
in the world with your web free wallet
um and then acquire Bitcoin anonymously
my camera keeps tilting down but I'm
gonna see if I can tighten it up a
little bit also your Wi-Fi is a little
scratchy by the way your your little
pixelated oh man you're a little
pixelated
okay well hopefully someone's trying to
censor the message here I know that's I
always say that I I actually did an
interview once um with this like number
one conspiracy theorist and I was
explaining why bitcoin's so amazing and
I lost my voice at that exact moment it
was like a two-hour interview and at
that moment my voice went
um okay so um thank you for explaining
all of that I think it's it's really
fascinating what I'd like to
um understand is how does this then help
um firstly secure the network but also
what do people need do they need Asic
mining machines do they need some kind
of a lumen machine you know once they've
bought the um the hash power from your
Marketplace what then do they need to
mine the Bitcoin
so
um we're trying to make this as easy as
possible
um yes you know right now it's this this
is very
um early on technology so in order to
have the full uh validation of what your
risk of what you're buying which is the
hash rate flow uh you're going to have
to download the lumren wallet which is
that the proxy node it's kind of that go
between that checks your product as you
receive it
um so you would go onto the Lumen
Marketplace
um so if you go to loomirin.io there's a
Marketplace link now this is all a
closed beta right now uh we're planning
to launch this in the next month or so
um we're still ironing out a few bugs
because it is highly Technical and
trying to
um do this you know fully decentralized
and Anonymous and still approvable
um it is not an easy problem to solve I
often tell the team you know if this was
easy someone else would have already
done it uh we've been at this for now
two years
um writing the code testing the code
iterating on it
um working on mining pool infrastructure
to make sure that you know we we
actually have
um all the pieces in place that this
ecosystem is going to need
um so in order to purchase Lumen hash
rate what you do is go to lumen.io
You'll click on the link to the
marketplace you'll connect your web3
wallet and then you'll see all of the
hash power contracts listed right there
and those are on-chain contracts
um so you know you don't have to go
through the Lumen Marketplace we just
have built like a user interface on top
of these smart contracts to make it easy
for you
um really anyone
um could actually build an interface on
top of these contracts uh so once you
have your web free wallet connected you
simply purchase the contract and you
enter your routing destination so
basically where do you want the hash
rate sent to for the majority of the
users this is going to be their mining
pool account so they could go to slush
pool they could go to F2 pool they could
go to ant pool they could uh sign up for
an account they will get the routing
information and their username from
there and this is the information
they'll put into the marketplace
um there is you know it's a little bit
technical it's a if you've never mined
before if you've never worked in this
ecosystem before you know we're writing
guides for it we have the telegram
channel that we're going to be answering
questions for once the marketplace goes
live to help people through this process
um but the end goal is to make it as
easy as possible for anyone with a web 3
wallet to acquire Bitcoin uh
decentralized anonymously through
hashrate
and so they don't need to be buying any
of that Bitcoin mining equipment no A6
nothing correct correct the the Bitcoin
mining equipment we're going to be
treating it a lot like AWS which is for
those who don't know AWS is Amazon web
services uh so Amazon is a is a massive
global company that sells all those
products that you you've you know come
to love you know as far as everything
from the Alexa products to just about
any product on Earth you can you can
open up an Amazon account you can buy
Amazon stuff but the majority of
Amazon's income is actually through AWS
it's actually their web hosting services
and not a lot of people know that they
actually have server Farms or I guess a
server facilities data centers all over
the world with servers in them and they
sell web services
um so similar to what AWS is we really
see that this is the future of mining
where you have
um these mining Farms set up all over
the world and they're selling cash power
and that hash power is all going to
funnel into a Marketplace and then those
that want to use the hash power will
purchase it and mine with it
so does everything that we've spoken
about then promote long-time security
for the Bitcoin Network
yes absolutely so and this is something
that I'm I'm really passionate about
because you know we are putting our our
life's work into this technology you
know we've invested billions and
billions of dollars of time
infrastructure and and just straight up
cash into Bitcoin
um we want to make sure that it lasts
and when you see things like
centralization around mining pools when
you see things around centralization for
the control of hash rate
um those are red flags in my book
um so we want to make sure that this
ecosystem lasts and in order to do that
we need to make sure that it's both both
distributed and decentralized right so
to get both of them right now we have
distributed we have nodes all over the
world but we need it to be decentralized
so the decision makers around
transaction processing
um needs to be decentralized through the
global
um distribution of cash rate
yeah and I think it's um I love that
distinction that you made earlier
between
um distributed and decentralized it's a
great Point
um I actually had never considered I
mean it goes without saying when you're
you know when you're interested in in
this kind of space but I'd never
actually had that distinction at the
Forefront of my mind so that that's
really interesting
um and another concern I'm always
hearing um particularly from the world
economic forum is that Bitcoin is bad
for the environment so I'm interested to
understand does lumarin reduce or solve
this concern in any way
oh my goodness
um so first first of all like Bitcoin
being bad for the environment it's just
it's kind of silly
um you know because it's it's layered on
so many premise right
um first of all why is why is Bitcoin
bad for the environment oh because
Bitcoin mining uses electricity so this
proof of work
um uh ecosystem use electricity and the
misnomer now that we're believing is
using electricity is bad for the
environment okay why is using
electricity bad for the environment well
it's because creating electricity is bad
for the environment and we say okay well
why is creating literacy bad for the
environment oh because it's uh burning
fossil fuels it's burning coal it's
burning oil or natural gas
um to create electricity well first of
all that's not even how the majority of
the electricity in this world is created
number one uh number two two there's so
many regulations now around the certain
types of electricity
um that this idea that you have these
big bad uh you know fossil fuel plants
that are polluted the environment to
create electricity really is very much a
thing of the past now
um you know the amount of hydroelectric
facilities have the amount of nuclear
facilities we have the amount of solar
and wind generation we have it's really
tipping the scales on production so
creating electricity is not bad for the
environment for the majority of the
power grids especially here in the U.S
if you go to just about any minor in the
U.S they'll be able to tell you exactly
what their mix of power is how much
renewable they have um how much a
nuclear winds uh solar you know they're
they're actually very very on top of
what their energy mix is
um so the majority of the world's miners
are incredibly responsible when it comes
to how they're generating Bitcoin and
how they're you know what kind of
electricity they're using
um so let me fix this here so so you
know that that's one thing um the second
thing is a lot of
um you know Bitcoin miners actually work
with the local energy grids to do uh
curtailment and they'll actually ramp
down the amount of electricity they use
when the grid needs to needs more power
than when the when the consumers don't
need that much power the Bitcoin miners
will ramp up again now what this
actually does is it balances the
electricity grid What A lot of people
don't understand is you can only use
electricity or you can only create
electricity when someone's using
electricity okay there's no just crate
electricity and you know fill this grid
and and let people use it when they need
it it's electricity only flows when
you're using it if you're not using
electricity there's no committed circuit
no electricity will flow
um so you'll have things like battery
arrays trying to take up some like
excess electricity that's incredibly
expensive but that's a whole I mean I
could talk for hours on balancing
electricity grid
the thing to know is this is one of the
hardest things when it comes to an
electricity Grid or a power grid is
balancing it you know here in the U.S
you know we have about I think it's like
a 0.4 Hertz tolerance before we have
blackouts on balancing the grid if you
put too much electricity on the grid
that you're not using the frequency
electricity goes up and you have a
blackout you don't put enough
electricity on the grid that you know
people are using too much then you'll
have lower frequency on the grid and
you'll have a blackout so balancing the
grid is incredibly important now with
renewable energy like solar panels and
wind you can't just turn them off and on
when the wind is blowing the turbine on
the the wind generator is rotating and
you're creating electricity uh when this
when the sun is shining the solar panels
creating electricity you don't just ramp
it up and ramp it down you don't turn it
off and turn it on with nuclear Hydro
gas you can can regulate how much
electricity you're use or you're
creating to balance the grid so with
renewable sources and this is the
takeaway from all of this with renewable
sources it's incredibly hard to ramp up
and ramp down production to do what they
call it load following okay now with
Bitcoin mining you can turn off the
miners and turn them back on very
quickly so you can do what's called
production following this completely
flips the script and the the key
takeaway is Bitcoin mining actually
solves an incredible problem for the
renewable energy industry is it actually
allows us to balance the grid for
renewable energy so when you have States
like California here in the United
States that's requiring the energy on
the grid in California to be 100
renewable by 2035 they pass that law and
they have no clue how to do that Bitcoin
mining is actually the only way to do
that currently because it's the only
thing that could use a hundred percent
of electricity 100 of the time and
actually be profitable so
long story short Bitcoin mining actually
solves this idea of renewable energy at
scale
um It's actually an incredible timing
for the technology uh lumerin and the
Lumen Marketplace wants to take all that
new hash power that's going to be coming
on the grid and keeping it decentralized
so the state of California wants to set
up massive mining facilities in the
desert of pumps you know in the deserts
outside Palm Springs to balance their
massive solar array we don't want the
state of California deciding where they
send that hash rate we want them to sell
off the hatch rate to people that want
to mine with it and then those miners
then get to decide what mining for or
what node they're back
it's so fascinating to me that um this
isn't something which people are
intellectually honest about
um I wanna I wanna just talk a little
bit more about balancing the energy grid
because this is so new and you know I
hear I hear this happens in Texas
actually
um so so you're saying because it's
renewable energy there's really no way
of course to turn it off and I mean I I
don't know but so you're saying that the
energy grid has to be balanced because
if it's too much you'll have a power cut
and what if it's too little you also
have a power cut you're saying
it's just you have blackouts yeah
because the the so you know like here in
the US
um the the frequency at which our power
it's it's AC alternating current so you
have this you have this back and forth
of electrons
um through the the power grid that that
is happening at you know at a certain
frequency right
um now if you put too much electricity
on the grid that frequency goes up if
you don't put enough electricity on the
grid the frequency goes down
um you can imagine it like water in
pipes if if you put too much water in a
pipe the pressure's gonna be super high
so when you turn on your faucet it's
just going to explode right
um if you don't put enough water in the
pipes you don't have enough pressure so
when you turn on the faucet it's just
going to become dribbling out right so
you can you can imagine
um the the frequency on the power grid
to be kind of like pressure in water
pipes you don't want the pressure to be
too high or it's going to cause damage
and you don't want the pressure to be
too low or it's just things aren't going
to work
same thing with electricity that's so
fascinating and this becomes this this
balancing becomes a real issue when we
start moving to Renewables is that the
idea that's why that's such an issue now
right correct you know if we stay with
the water analogy Renewables are just
constantly pushing more water in the
pipes right yes so there's a problem
where you're saying well
in the middle of summer it's super hot
people are using a ton of water they're
constantly their sprinklers are on their
hoses are running whatever you need all
the water pressure you can get so they
build all these machines
um that are just going to push water
into the pipes as fast as possible now
if winter comes around it's snowing no
one's using that much water and having
water in the pipes is actually dangerous
you can't just you have to literally
turn off or disconnect these water
machines but they're still pushing water
out what are you going to do with the
water right
so it's the same thing with uh solar
panels you could go disconnect the solar
panels but there's no way of just
regulating
um you know instantly the amount of
solar panels that are you know pushing
electricity onto the grid
um so the the key is how do you use all
this excess water that's being pushed
into pipes when you don't need it well
Bitcoin mining we'll we'll use 100 of it
100 of the time just more power the
better I love it it's such a good
analogy the water analogy thank you for
explaining so in a minute we're going to
talk about the markets um because
Bitcoin is of course pumping but before
we do
um I just want to finish this topic by
understanding for those who want to mine
Bitcoin you know they want to get that
non-kyc Bitcoin from anywhere in the
world but they're not going to buy the
actual Machinery they want to use Lumen
they want to just buy the hash power so
they can then send it to a pool and be
done with it and just get their you know
their fair share of their Bitcoin so how
do they do this where do they go
so I mean there's there's currently
centralized services that you can use
for renting hash power
um renting mining rigs um there are a
lot of services that have been around
for years that do this uh in a
centralized fashion
um what we're doing is decentralized
it's very very different it's actually
going through smart contracts on another
Network So currently uh we're watching
The Marketplace on the ethereum mainnet
um we can launch the same Marketplace on
you know binance or cello or any other
evm
um the goal is to eventually launch our
own lumorin network because this is a
very a highly specific use case
um we don't want to use another Network
that's going to be cramming a bunch of
irrelevant data in these other uh
General compute you know we're we're
doing something that's highly specific
where we're data routing through a
socket socket connections so we're
designing a network specifically for
this what we call decentralized piping
um because our network is meant for
decentralized piping for just setting up
the data flows we could essentially use
our Network underneath all the other
networks as almost a layer zero network
is what we're pushing for that's still
probably a year out or so just depending
on our um our community involvement our
development schedule
so right now we're just working on a
decentralized hatch rate Marketplace
that we're going to be launching on top
of ethereum the goal is to have this
live within the next couple months we're
internally testing we've we started
expanding our testing ring where we're
doing kind of friends and family right
now bringing them in for feedback it is
a high it's a very complicated thing to
achieve where you have a buyer and a
seller that don't trust each other but
they're exchanging a a very valuable
product that at any point someone could
try to cheat the other person out of it
so we're we're building a decentralized
trustless ecosystem to exchange this
product and still have safety between
the buyer and the seller and that's a
hard puzzle to solve so long answer to a
short question
um you could go to lumren.io for updates
and as soon as the marketplace is live
you'll be able to access it through
bloomerang.io
okay great so what I'll do is I will
leave the link to loomeran.io in the
YouTube description straight after this
after we're done um this is obviously
we're going live right now so once we're
not live anymore I will leave a link to
loomirin.io
um so that's really fascinating have I
have it do you is there anything else
about Lumen you feel like I missed or
did we or do is did we cover everything
I mean way possible uh you know as far
as it you know it has to do with hash
rates
um you know lumerin is is really the the
only way currently to make this a
decentralized system of uh peer-to-peer
distribution of hash rate
um so that's what we're really excited
about eventually there's going to be
other use cases for Lumen that we're
exploring it's this idea of being able
to broker an opening and closing of
sockets from one device to another
device through a smart contract
um there are so many use cases for
things like that and you know I was even
talking to the team a couple months ago
because the reality is when I call
someone on my cell phone I'm actually
opening a data stream from my phone to
their phone
and that's happening through a
centralized service or a phone company
and I'm using this uh you know
this seven digit or you know 10 digit
number that I do not own
um you know as my identity right so
whether you're going through T-Mobile or
Verizon or one of the international
carriers our identity is tied to a a 10
digit number that we do not control it
can be taken away from us at any point
we're using as two-factor authentication
on all our social media like does anyone
else think this is an insane other than
me that we're trying all of identity to
something that we don't control oh I do
so so that's something else that we can
use lumerin for is we can actually
create peer-to-peer communication
channels
um through a smart contract so now
instead of giving someone your phone
number for them to contact you you can
give them your um ethereum address you
can give them an NF you can actually
assign them an nft that is routing rules
so basically they can only contact you
from a certain time to another time uh
under certain premises and then you can
you can take away those rules at any
point
um so the the real goal is eventually to
get to a communication system where it's
transactional communication uh I will no
longer receive spam people can't email
me unless I've given them permission to
email me
um they can't uh text me they can't uh
call me unless I've given them
permission to do so
um this is the way communication and
identity should work
um but that's that's a little ways down
the road but we'll get there
I'm sure a lot of governments and
telecom companies will have something to
say about that though oh I'm sure they
will all of that sounds amazing um it
still blows my mind that people use
their mobile phone numbers
um as 2fa so please don't do that that
leads to sim swaps and all these awful
fraudulent things that can happen to you
um and yeah that's really interesting I
think you know I think owning your own
data and the more decentralization the
better so let's talk a little bit about
the market right now because Bitcoin is
pumping out of nowhere nineteen thousand
two hundred dollars today I think that's
the yeah oh 90 300 today that's that's
the 24 hour high so what's your take why
why is it pumping first we'll start
there
um
well I mean there's there's a lot of
things uh that are happening right one
it's a new year so
um people re-establish their tax base uh
selling off at the end of last year
rebuying this year um that's that's one
thing
um you know another thing could be a
change in economic circumstances we're
seeing uh certain things happen in the
economy that are looking positive uh
that that's affecting the market now
unfortunately the crypto markets are so
uh very much tied to the the general
economy which you would think would
happen in Reverse uh if our economy is
weak you think Bitcoin would be strong
because people are trying to get out of
the US dollar uh for whatever reason
um it's very much tied uh to each other
so the same people that are speculating
on the stock markets are speculating on
the crypto markets
um I don't know how that makes sense uh
it should be a hedge against the stock
markets in the general economy but you
know at some point in the future I
really do think the two will be come
unpegged and people will realize that
net crypto and Bitcoin specifically is
very much a shelter and hedge against uh
General economies and that's when we'll
see Bitcoin truly break out from the
rest of the ecosystem uh but for now
that you know For Better or Worse
they're connected to each other
um so we're seeing a lot of positive
indicators in the space I think the
shock value of FTX has worn off
um you know we're seeing a we're seeing
some Rumblings around Genesis we're
seeing some Rumblings between you know
Barry and Cameron um for the the Gemini
versus dcg stuff
um but it's not really moving the needle
I think people are still very kind of
under the seams bullish I was at a
conference last weekend with a lot of
project leaders and everyone's still
very bullish they're still keeping their
heads down and building
um so what's interesting is you know a
lot of people have been in space for a
long time will say oh we're just going
through the same cycle we've been
through the cycle four or five times
before we're we're in the same
three-year cycle now the question is
because everyone knows that we're in the
same three year cycle is this going to
break the three-year cycle and I I think
that might be what we're seeing um so
it's one of two things it's either a
bear trap so it's going up um where
people are gonna liquidate and it's
gonna drop again
um yeah one thing that could happen or
two we're we're breaking the three year
cycle because everyone's expecting the
three-year cycle
I'm expecting the three to four year
cycle
um I I think this is a bear trap I'm not
sure but I I am not fan bullish and I
think you know we're seeing we're seeing
it trade like a normal stock because I
think institutions are trading Bitcoin
like a normal stock
um but you know I still regard Bitcoin
as
um as as that inflation hedge um you
know I always say right now it's sitting
at um the all-time high of 2017.
slow and steady slow and steady that's
what I say so I know you sort of gave us
your you know two takes this is either
like um this is either
um you know a bear Market rally but
how long do you think this bear Market
is going to go on for do you think we've
seen the worst
um I know you don't think dcg is is
gonna is gonna be another FTX
uh
I don't know I can't I can't make that
prediction I don't know what's going on
and it seems there
um I will say that
one of the worst mistakes I ever thought
I did in my life was buying Bitcoin when
it was at 900 in 2014.
I thought it was a terrible mistake when
I when I when I saw it hit 900 like
because it was at 1200 and then it
dropped and it was at 900 and I bought a
bunch of Bitcoin at 900 and I was like
oh no what did I do because it kept
dropping and you know then it went down
to 150 130 and I hovered you know kind
of the low 100s
[Music]
um for quite a while before it started
coming back up but it took you know
years before it got back up over 900 and
I thought this was one of the worst
mistakes ever right there's a lot of
people sitting right now that that buy
in the 30s bought in the 40s bottom 50s
and they're thinking the same thing
right but the reality is is we're still
incredibly new in this technology and
the technology has not changed the
soundness of what we're building has not
changed you know we're in an ecosystem
right now where anyone with a check from
your checking account has both your
account information and your routing
information you can actually empty your
checking account they can reach in and
create an ACH transaction and enter your
checking account there is very little
security in banking
um anyone with your credit card number
or a picture of your credit card then
all of a sudden you know order food
online and go shopping online and you're
paying for that you know and now we have
all these you know fraud uh services and
all these LifeLock services and and you
know things things try to protect your
identity but in reality is our
information is very very public when it
comes to banking when it comes to social
identity we have very little control
over our finances in a very stubborn way
Bitcoin and cryptocurrency solves that
actually gives you the power no one else
can access your Bitcoin account but you
unless you're incredibly foolish with
your private Keys
um so you know which is you know there's
a whole another uh conversation about
how to properly store your Bitcoin how
to properly transact but
at the end of the day if you're storing
your private Keys correctly you know if
you have a mnemonic that you memorize
and then you delete all other sources
that mnemonic no one else can access
that but you no one else can control
your funds but you know government can
reach in and take it no financial
institution can seize it I mean that's
true freedom and that's what we're
building for so when you consider the
world economy you have 21 million
Bitcoins that will ever exist and a lot
of those have already been mined we're
already what between 19 and 20 million
have been mined
um
and we we have barely like what one and
a half million left to go or thereabouts
you know that's not a lot more Bitcoin
that's an ecosystem and a lot of Bitcoin
has been burned already so at the end of
the day we're trading an incredibly rare
asset when you buy Bitcoin you're buying
an incredibly rare asset and it is the
only you know coin that at scale is
currently being mined and backed by
decentralized compute power it's not a
proof of State coin so it's not mob rule
it is decentralized Hash rate so
anywhere someone has cheap electricity
they can enter into this ecosystem and
participate
um that's the amazing thing about proof
of work I will get in debates with
people on proof of work group mistake
all day long I truly think proof of work
and Bitcoin
um is going to be the the value store
moving into the future so whether you
bought it thirty thousand forty thousand
fifty thousand you know No One's Gonna
care in three years because it's
is just going to become more and more
rare and and more and more utility
around it
I totally agree with you and um I'm
going to put an idea to you which
somebody put to me the other day
um so just digest it sit on it and you
know let me know what you think
um so I said to somebody you know
Bitcoin of course is proof of work and
everything and somebody said well
actually it's proof of sake and I was
like educate me why is it proof of stake
and they said because you have to buy
the Machinery so you have to like have a
stake in the machinery and I was like
yeah but that's not how it works and
they were sort of like well you know x
amount of money you have to put down in
order to be able to mine Bitcoin so like
at its base level it's proof of stake
and I was just like no that doesn't sit
right with me like what'd you say to
that so yes at the at the very have you
heard that before by the way yes I I've
heard it before my buddy Marshall is big
on saying that like okay
um so yes at the the very basis of stake
um you're you're staking uh cost of
electricity your staking cost of
Hardware yes um you're putting up a
large amount um in order to do this but
but there's still like an air gap there
if you will because you're still having
to guess the correct number to solve the
block to get paid out
um there is no guarantee that just
because you've put this stake into the
ecosystem that you're going to get paid
out
um there is still a factor of luck to it
right so
um what I'll say is it's locked up
potential
um so whether you're in a uh proof of
State coin
um when you stake that coin you're
having to lock up potential you're
locking up the liquidity of that coin in
order to earn on it or earn interest or
mint other blocks with it in Bitcoin
you're having to lock up potential
you're having to take finances and put
them into infrastructure in order to
create more coins
um so in in the Raw sense of stake I
would say yes that that's that's a
correct statement
um and if you just want to confuse the
hell out of people then yes that's
that's a correct statement as well
okay thank you for clarifying that but
no I think it's interesting I think you
make the perfect point that it is still
about that luck
in you know guessing
um you know Finding excuse me finding
you know the puzzle was there as they as
they put it um and guessing that that
right number so yeah it's still proof of
work it's just if you want to confuse
people and make them uncomfortable you
tell them it's proof of stake
um so Ryan it's been so fascinating
speaking with you um you know learning
about hash power learning how we can
further decentralize the Bitcoin Network
given
you know different countries are
cracking down on Bitcoin mining and it's
it's important to decentralize the
Bitcoin Network as much as possible so
how can people follow you follow what
lumirin is doing and um obviously get
get involved I'm going to leave a link
in the description below after the show
but how can people follow you and
everything boomeran's doing
uh yeah you can uh follow us on Twitter
so hello lumerin um at Twitter
um we're on telegram just go to
limburg.io you'll see all the links uh
you can follow me on Twitter it's R
Condren I think you you already uh I
think linked to me on Twitter I
unfortunately am not Super Active on
social media
um I probably should become more active
according to my marketing team
um but you know you can follow me as
well uh maybe maybe I'll tweet a recipe
or something
no you should be I agree with your
marketing team Twitter is where it's at
um Twitter's great but um Brian thank
you so much for coming on it's been such
a pleasure speaking with you
yeah absolutely it's been great and guys
thank you so much for watching please
don't forget to follow Ryan check out
loomeran and also don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe if you
enjoyed the show we will see you all
next time bye bye